[Musik]
das ist dem bioladen bush tucker mit dem
baubeginn hatte ich noch muss
codieraktion wenn man steht was noch
geht nachher weniger muskulös und es
richtig dass noch einige auf sagt sturm
herd und aaron hunt strecke und
unterrichtet jetzt hier die mission
ausschließen
diese veranstaltung das ist für uns wir
drauf haben deutlich das habe ich noch
nicht räumen
manchmal schaue mir das an die wirklich
nicht eben das messer im rücken der
frauen die möglichkeit so die forscher
handelt von einer woche eishockey und
die zeit langsam flirtet und der jetzt
tragen gstaad nicht verlassen in das sie
das ist auch unsere gesamtsituation
analogen thomas jung ist und externe
clouds lichtenau ich meine freundin
antje ist rechtsmedizinerin sie sagt sie
habe den besten job denn es gibt und ich
versuche zu verstehen wie geht man damit
um jeden tag dem tod zu begegnen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
ich habe noch nicht sagen noch lektion
für die einfach plakate ja froh dass mir
nur mit newsletter und
[Musik]
für die angeordnete obduktion wird die
leiche von einem bestatter ins institut
für rechtsmedizin in bern überführt
normalerweise ist hier dazu tritt für
private streng untersagt aber ich darf
meine freundin zwei tage lang bei ihrer
arbeit begleiten mitgenommen habe ich
viel halbwissen eine vorstellung von der
rechtsmedizin habe ich vor allem aus dem
fernsehen aus serien wie der bestatter
oder sie es seien bis jetzt zwar die
ziele dass jeder christ ich finde ich
mache und ich mache aus oder sicherung
realistisches gibt jene es gibt jeder
lyko ausmacht die macher das
medizinische aufgaben machen spiele sich
für die sache die machen fertig sagt die
laufen ja mit chrome os für diese stufe
tier das läuft nicht machen weil ich
seine aufgaben komiker bild eines
antiken mit aqua de coco befragen
das ist natürlich auf gehabt dass das
team nicht an ich mache ich es zinke zur
forensischen medizin gehören auch
untersuchungen von lebenden personen
männlich jetzt wirklich lebensgefährlich
verletzt weil ich verletzt war und ist
es mir für lässige dokumentieren
dokumentiere heißt verteilt und davon
kriminelle aus dem übersetzte zwischen
medizin und jüdische anti hat dienst
falls ein außergewöhnlicher todesfall
gemeldet wird müsste sie sofort wieder
ausrücken
noch bleibt es still
mit den gewonnenen fakten werden nicht
selten kriminal fälle aufgedeckt
in diesen räumen wird gewebe untersucht
unfallhergang werden bis ins detail
rekonstruiert und toxikologische
abklärungen gemacht
das 80 jahre alte gebäude steht unter
denkmalschutz
drm liegen die leichen nicht im keller
sondern im ersten stock hier arbeitet
transportierte damen ist hier noch nicht
identifiziert dass wir uns orientieren
wenn man glück noch auf ca ich habe ja
auch qualitative und die
mitgliederinitiative doch dargestellt
ich bin menschlich bin ich so bis hier
bis hier und hat ihm ist der
sprachstörung verlassen und erlangen
erlauben spannende weil ich irgendwie
gut geht und ganz viel der krieg für
nahe schien
welche person sie tot ist vor der show
ist die energie graz zusammen was ich
hier jetzt aktiv wo sie vor dem haus je
nachdem
der erste tag in der rechtsmedizin geht
zu ende
ohne weiteren einsatz doch angst dienst
geht weiter auch abends also wir uns mit
freunden treffen ist sie auf pikett hier
erlebe ich anti so wie ich sie seit 25
jahren kennen
lustig laut und äußerst lebendig
jetzt das nie hätte ich damals gedacht
dass meine schulfreundin einmal jeden
tag mit toten verbringen würde
wir sehen die mathematik haben warum
macht jeder eigentlich habe ich nicht
mal
dass die arbeit eine rechtsmedizinerin
doch etwas mit mathematik zu tun hat
werde ich später noch erfahren
zuerst lerne ich gestorben wird nicht zu
bürozeiten im berner oberland ist ein
außergewöhnlicher todesfall gemeldet
worden
die verstorbene person liegt seit
einigen tagen in der wohnung ist das für
ein tier besonders schlimm
denn für eine verstaatlichung guter
letzt stand verstorbener leiste und
gestorben wieder einen job und es wird
jeden tag gestartet
du bist
ist mit persönlich mit
ich war ok und der firmen geschlafen
nein
wedemann
recht
kurz vor der ankunft erfahren wir ein
tötungsdelikt kann nicht ausgeschlossen
werden
die staatsanwältin vor ort entscheidet
dass wir mit der kamera draußen bleiben
müssen
mit
dann achtung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der wohnung für tante die legal
inspektion durch trotz falles wird die
leiche routinemäßig fotografiert und
ausgezogen
[Musik]
damit decken
die dort im swat tal
ich glaube dass dort schon lange man
noch mal machen
die lok in der schnellste hobby mit
ungefähr 90 minuten später kann eine
fremdeinwirkung ausgeschlossen werden
und die leiche wird freigegeben
für antje ist der fall damit
abgeschlossen
wir lassen den einsatzort hinter uns den
fall eines geruch aber haben wir
unfreiwillig mitgenommen
wie gehst du die gäste mit dem wenn du
so eine innere uhr mi nach wunsch
es ist nicht so schlimm
die schwellung
glück sie auch sehr wichtig diesen jobs
in den usa wirken sie schon schmecken
für die bz
[Musik]
bereits fünf stunden später sind wir
zurück in der rechtsmedizin punkt acht
uhr informieren sich alle mitarbeiter
gegenseitig über ihre fälle auch an tier
bringt ihre kollegen auf den aktuellen
stand ihrer arbeit nach 24 stunden an
ihrer seite bin ich beeindruckt von
meiner freundin und von ihrer arbeit
gleichzeitig weiß ich noch nicht wie ich
mit all den bildern und gerüchen umgehen
kann
weil ich dann bist du tot im
herstellungs- mit je 20 euro angst keine
angst aber es ist wichtig ein
überzeugtes jahren die kita ähnliches
jetzt hier kurse und dadurch ja dafür
hat der moskauer mit klose tun jetzt
muss er mit den 800ern ich raus dafür
interessieren und aber das hat mich
fasziniert passiert fasziniert - das ist
die sonne über machen und armenische
komme dann sind ihr traumjob hat anti
aber auch verändert für den privat
natürlich schön wenn man das nicht macht
das ist einfach so dass es nicht mit
nicole verstecken das beruhigt mich ist
der mini itx viel energie
die obduktion einer weiteren leiche
steht bevor
der tote körper wurde zur vorbereitung
vom radiologin in einem
computertomographen gescannt freddy
zeigt an wo sie bei der obduktion
genauer hinschauen diese bilder könnten
auch von lebenden personen stammen
träumen denn nicht alle ärzte davon
leben zu retten
bestätige sich aber genau dass ich
irgendwas mit drin mit am werk oder der
krankheit von mensch und tier richtig
entwickeln und man macht diese nach uns
kriegen ist und wo es später wieder da
und konnte mir zum amt regime ihnen hier
haben die un am schluss wie es auch
fertig es ist weder kitschig oder der
erachten
zum schluss um strich sehr sympathisch
aber mir geht's an pharmexx resultat
rom luca zurück
[Musik]
jetzt nicht
red
ob auch ich parat wenn die situation
fühlt sich abstrakt an der körper der da
liegt sieht bei einer unechten buch
fertig zwei zentimeter tief
und der große das na ja nichts also ich
habe endlich wieder anziehen ist einfach
ein schlechter konnte es dann
sitzblockade moment loki schmidt aus
personal logistik arbeitet konzentriert
auf das onyx serie und strukturen die
blutige dass die sachen mit dem faktor
ich mit einem interview
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der suche nach der todesursache
werden routinemäßig schädel bauch und
brust geöffnet in speziellen fällen auch
der rücken
das stimmt überhaupt nicht
es ist passiert und das habe ich auch
zuerst aber ich war es wenig zusammen
und hat mit ihr unterhalten seine
angeschnittene strafen kommen noch
trauben selbstverlust ist du das tust
jährlich über den teamchef auch bei der
gst und nicht nur über die exporte
deutschlands und in der tat wer sich
selber die ti chips kommen sie bloß mit
erinnerung an das team verstärken jetzt
diverse versuche man kann auch kein
passiert richtig und behauptete sein
von den inneren organen werden proben
entnommen wie spätere oder
weiterführende untersuchungen
ja
alle arbeitsschritte verfolgt ahnt ihr
mit einem ziel die unbekannten in der
gleichung zu finden
woran ist dieser mensch gestorben und
vor allem ist ein anderer daran schuld
schmid status ja ich in die risse und
zwar über die workshops heißt es
blutiger um der hütet das habe ich auch
privat diesmal gab's not effekt ein
kabinett mit der jetzt konzessions hatte
herr j
ich mache ein haus wie es jetzt gemacht
die brauche ich auch wichtig von von
martin hauffe aber auch heute um
kollegen der oper oder giftig noch hat
das schmucke blog schönes leben nach und
so häufig besteht dagegen sehr
pragmatisch
vielleicht vielleicht malen ist aber die
bisher sagt er pragmatisch aber
letztlich der dies braucht ihre eigene
staatlichkeit irgendwie verändert wird
die brühe aus dem start welche nicht der
mann ist das nadelöhr ems passiert
fertig
das motto bei zeit großflächig zerrissen
und ein geblutet
ich glaube dass er mich so ehrlich
direkt ungeschönt so präsentiert sich
der ton
und genau so geht auch am tier mit ihm
um
der respekt für meine freundin könnte
nach meinem besuch nicht größer sein
nach 25 jahren und diesen zwei tagen
glaube ich sie zu verstehen
[Musik]